our word has never been in more danger
modulus fair
[Music]
hey everybody its charlie they dropped a
new Artemis Fowl trailer I got a bunch
of requests to do a video about it
explaining the story and some of the
easter eggs
the director is Kenneth Brand now he
directed the first Thor movie he talked
a lot about the Thor movie when talking
about Artemis Fowl what a coincidence
Disney franchise they would also be
tying it to the Marvel stuff so if
you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos we're
doing an IMAX ticket giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video the
movie is based on the very first book
it's a series of books just like Harry
Potter but it takes some more science
fiction Bend on the fantasy magic tropes
so it's a lot of magic and science
fiction together instead of just being
magic like the Harry Potter series the
protagonist as you can see is a 12 year
old Artemis Fowl he's a child prodigy in
head of his family's criminal empire the
foul criminal empire he took over from
his father there might be some sort of
explainer that they have at the
beginning of the movie explaining how it
is he became head of their family
because his father was a very big figure
he disappeared in this big scheme that
he was trying to pull artemis learns
about the family's criminal enterprise
takes it over because he is so smart and
because he's a child he has a relatively
grey morality because they're doing very
bad things because they're criminals but
the story is all about the push-pull
between the good and evil inside him
because he's part of an evil family and
starts out doing very selfish things
with his abilities but becomes a hero so
in that same way Kenneth Branagh tied
this to the Thor series so like it
starts out where you try to blend the
world of science and magic like they do
in the Marvel Universe with a Thor
Asgardian technology it seems like magic
but it's really super advanced science
they even get into that during the
Doctor Strange movie about how they
weave their spells by pulling dark
energy from another dimension
within the world of the story there's a
couple different groups of people you
have Artemis Fowl who's a normal human
just incredibly smart then you have the
world of the fairies and magical
creatures which live very far below the
earth the place where they live is
called Haven City where you see this car
flying around with this big magical
Vista but that's them going beneath the
earth into Haven City there are a couple
of really important places here but you
don't go to some of them to the later
books it's a lot like the Harry Potter
books where you dip your toe in these
magical places that are all around you
the
you never knew about then you slowly
start to see them throughout the series
and assuming that this gets sequels you
just see the rest of them because Haven
City is supposed to be one of the last
places on earth that fairies can exist
without having to worry about being
bothered by humans
the other big city is Atlantis I know
we're all talking about Atlantis because
of the Aquaman movie that's coming up
later this month this movie isn't coming
out till next summer so this is just
meant to be like an early teaser to show
you what the world is going to look like
what the characters are gonna look like
but all the footage they show up
essentially tells you the entire story
of the first book
so when Artemis takes over his family's
criminal enterprise he learns that the
event that caused his father's
disappearance also wiped out their
family's fortune so because he's a
genius and it's a criminal family that's
where the heist aspect of the story
picks up because that's sort of what
sets things off he wants to pull an epic
score to replenish his family's gold and
he's had this long-running theory that
fairies exist the relationship between
humans and fairies is a lot like muggles
and magical people in the Harry Potter
series they make it so that the humans
don't know that they exist but really
smart people like Artemis start to
figure it out
so what you see in the trailer is is him
going to Ho Chi Minh City like he does
during the first book and finding a
really drunk fairy and tricking or
conning that person into giving him
their special book of the people which
is like their compendium of fairy
knowledge and magical spells so when you
see all this code in cipher all over the
trailer that's actually the fairy
language that Artemis is able to decode
because he's a genius so he learns about
all their tricks where they live what
their history is so he uses that
knowledge to trap a fairy and ransom
them back to the other fairies for a
[ __ ] ton of gold surprise surprise the
fairy that he traps winds up being his
love interest and I don't see any good
footage of her in here but her name is
Captain Holly she's a member of the
lower elements police so the fairy
people have their own police force
commander Holly is like a really young
member of that team the main antagonist
is Judi Dench's character commander root
but she's the one doing the voice over
in the trailer talking about the
differences between the world of fairy
the world of man about how things are
getting worse and worse between them so
when you see all these spaceships coming
across the
Bay in this big battle here going on
with people shooting at each other this
is all probably towards the end of the
story because when Artemis is ransoming
captain Hawley back to the lower
elements police he keeps her locked
inside foul manner using fairy knowledge
from the special book that he stole to
trap her part of the problem that
Artemis has is that fairies are all
incredibly powerful magical people but
they do have certain rules that they're
bound by they have to replenish their
magic every once in a while so he has to
learn to use that knowledge against him
so a big part of especially the big
action set pieces later in the film is
him outwitting these crazy powerful
magical beings but like I said a big
part of Artemis's arc during the series
is going from being a very selfish
person at the beginning of the story to
being a very selfless person at the end
of the story so it's a really long
running series he develops a
relationship with Captain Hawley but in
the same way that the Harry Potter
novels sort of pace out the
relationships between the characters
because they're all really young when
the story starts out they grow as the
series goes on you really don't see them
start to acknowledge their feelings for
each other till much much later so I
don't know how much they're gonna get
into that during this first series but
the really interesting thing that they
do is that there's an epilogue at the
end of the first book where you have a
character narrating as if he's
remembering all the events of the book
in the future like this is decades in
the future in someone's reviewing a case
file on Artemis Fowl the person doing
this is dr. argon he's the leader of the
jay argon Institute which is sort of
this insane asylum for incredibly rich
people inside Haven City the world of
the fairies so it reads like this now
that you have reviewed the case file you
must realize what a dangerous creature
this fowl is talking about Artemis Fowl
there is a tendency to romanticize
Artemis to attribute to him qualities
that he does not possess the fact that
he used his wish to heal his mother is
not a sign of affection he did it simply
because the social services were already
investigating his case and it was only a
matter of time before he was put into
care remember Artemis Fowl is 12 years
old so if his mother weren't able to
care for him when his father disappeared
child services
in the real world would pick him up and
he get thrown into foster care the case
file goes on it says he kept the exist
of the people talking about fairies
quiet only so that he could continue to
exploit them over the years which he did
on several occasions his one mistake was
leaving captain short alive
Holly became the LEP s lower elements
police's foremost expert in the Artemis
Fowl cases and was invaluable in the
fight against the people's most feared
enemy this fight was to continue across
several decades ironically the greatest
triumph for both protagonists was the
time that they were forced to cooperate
during the Goblin insurgents but that's
another story and then it says details
on this are 94% accurate 6 % unavoidable
extrapolation so it's sort of the doctor
of this psychological facility trying to
examine Artemis in context thinking of
him is more of a villain in their story
but remember this is the fairies seeing
artemis as their mortal enemy because he
exploits them on so many occasions in
those different occasions wind up being
the events of the different books in the
series so if you want to tie this back
to the Thor movies think of Artemis Fowl
is a Loki type character a lot of people
see him as a villain even though a lot
of times what he's doing is ultimately
towards a greater purpose even though
you know during each step it might seem
like he's trying to throw you under the
bus but what'll happen is is we're
supposed to get that Avengers 4 trailer
really soon other big Disney trailers so
if we get any news about that I will
totally post a video click here for that
brand new Captain Marvel trailer and
click here to rewatch that big Lion King
remake trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]